When I started working on this problem,
or I guess when,
when it started working on me,
it was probably really in the mid
eighties and I found myself suffering
from two things.
One was a very lengthy sequence of
nightmares about nuclear destruction,
and they were very as affecting dreams
and associated with that was a sense of
amazement.
That dream that was,
that awful could reflect a reality that
could be that awful and an additional
amazement at the fact that despite the
production of thousands and tens and
thousands of weapons of unimaginable
destruction and the qualitative
qualitative change in human capacity
that represented that people could go
about their day to day lives without
acting as if anything fundamental
whatsoever had changed.
Now,
I've never really been able to figure
out why that disturbed me so much when
it seemed to not disturb to any profound
degree.
Most of the people I knew but doesn't
really matter.
Um,
the upshot of it was of it was that I
spent.
I probably spent my whole life trying to
understand what evil was and more
importantly,
what might be done about it.
Um,
it's a strange pursuit in some ways for
an academic done undertake because
academics tend to talk about academic
things.
And one thing you can say about evil is
that whatever it is,
it's not bloody well academic,
it's not an intellectual issue,
it's an existential issue and it's not a
theoretical issue,
it's an,
it's an issue that deals with that
absolute nature of reality.
And I guess sometimes I think that
people go into academia,
go into academia,
did shield themselves from having to ask
questions about the absolute nature of
reality.
So anyways,
I think before you can talk about
something before you can dare to talk
about something like evil,
you should do some thinking about what
it is that you're talking about is
definitionally speaking.
I learned this,
I believe from historian named Jeffrey
Burton,
Russell,
who wrote a very detailed history of the
idea of the devil and the 19 eighties
when such histories were,
were strange to say the least.
He was very interested in the history of
the embodiment of ideas of evil.
And one of the things he his work did
for me was to help me clarify the
distinction between two terrible things,
the distinction,
a distinction that has to be made,
and that's the distinction between
tragedy and evil and I don't think you
can talk about it evil at all until you
distinguish it from tragedy.
And so I'm going to try to distinguish
evil from tragedy by making some
reference to the essential existential
condition of human beings.
I would say that the nature of human
being is such that it consists of a
confrontation with the bounded finite,
with the unbounded infinite,
and those are the bare facts of the
matter.
And the facts are that the,
the world of experience as it presents
itself to us is literally and not
metaphorically complex beyond our
capacity to understand.
And that means that people deal in a
real sense on an ongoing basis with the
infinite.
And I believe that that fact is the
reason why religious experiences
essentially and belief is essentially
endemic to mankind.
It's a human universal and it's not
because people believe it's because
human existence as such consists of a
confrontation between the finite and the
infinite and religious systems merely
take that into account.
Now,
our finitude in the face of the infinite
has some inevitable consequences and I
would say those consequences are
essentially the existential conditions
of life.
The first of those consequences is that
the finite is always overwhelmed by the
infinite.
It has to be because it can't
encapsulate it,
and so what that means is that it's that
suffering is central to the nature of
human existence and suffering exists as
a consequence of the consequences of our
limitations.
I mean every single person who's alive
is going to die and every single person
who's alive,
who's going to deal with with serious
physical illness and mental distress,
if they don't suffer,
if they aren't suffering directly
immediately right now on their own,
it's almost inevitably the case that
every single person who walks the earth
is confronting the bare bones of reality
at that level in the guise of an
afflicted family member.
And so the fact of our affinity duties
is,
again,
no academic issue,
it's essential to the nature of our
being and we're forced to deal with it
on an ongoing basis.
So I would say insufficiency is built
into human experience and their
existential consequences to that.
Now,
I read something a long time ago and I
don't remember who wrote it,
but it was written about Jewish
commentary on the Torah.
God Is Omniscient,
omnipotent and omnipresent.
What does he lack?
Announcers,
limitation.
And that's,
that's a,
that's a riddle and announcer of
unparalleled brilliance as far as I'm
concerned because I think it speaks
deeply to something about the central
nature of existence itself and that is
without limitation.
There's no being.
Now that's a hard thing to understand,
but I think you can understand it in a
number of different ways.
The first thing you might want to
understand is that I played this game
with my students sometimes in my class.
I'll come up to a student to pick them
at poor victim at random and come up to
them and say,
okay,
we're going to play a game.
Say I.
They say,
okay,
and I say,
well,
you move first and they don't know what
to do,
and the reason for that is because the
limiting parameters of the game of not
being defined and as a consequence of
that,
they're are stunned by their infinite
freedom into complete and mobility.
And what that means in a sense is that
the,
in the absence of serious constraint,
there can be no choice,
no freedom,
no existence,
and I believe this to be fundamentally
true,
just as the fact that human being as
vulnerable is fundamentally true.
Here's another example I think is more,
it's more personal to me,
and it emerged in my imagination as a
consequence of my contemplation of my
son's vulnerability.
So I have children that are teenagers
now.
I still like them.
Um,
am i.
One of the things I was really struck by
when my children were little was how
perfect they were like,
and I believe that that was the
benevolence of God.
In a sense.
Children are tremendously difficult.
They're tremendous responsibility,
but they're so perfect and they manifest
that perfection in such a,
a remarkable way that that's the payment
for taking on the responsibility of
bringing them into the B,
into being,
in caring for them.
And the thing about being a parent is
that the vulnerability of people is made
manifest to you in a way that was never
the case prior to that.
And it's not.
It's haunting and it's beautiful,
but it's also exactly right in a way.
And I was thinking,
well,
look at my son,
he's a little kid and you know,
you've got to chase after him all the
time.
You can get sick.
People heard him,
uh,
you know,
people are going to be mean to him.
He's going to be disappointed in his
life.
He's vulnerable and,
and it's,
it's,
it's a constant tragic reality that he's
vulnerable.
And I thought,
well,
okay,
let's say we wanted to do something
about that.
So let's say we make them so that no one
can pick on him.
So he could inflate them to about 20
feet high and equip them with a metallic
scout.
And and uh,
and a cast iron exoskeleton,
and you could equip them with a
computerized intelligence that far
supersedes his own and you could remove
his vulnerabilities one by one
hypothetically,
and of course more and more we're in a
position where we could do that in
reality.
And one of the things I realized right
away was that as you remove the
vulnerabilities,
you remove the thing you love.
And then I started to understand more
deeply that vulnerability was a
precondition for human being and that
was a desirable preconditioned because
the things about human existence that
are wonderful and remarkable are so
integrally tied up with vulnerability
that they're actually inextricable.
The Jewish commentary.
What the infinite lacks is the finite is
a more abstract way of getting at the
same thing.
If you could do absolutely anything you
wanted at any point and be anywhere you
want it to be,
anything you wanted,
and if,
if there was nothing that was out of
your reach,
there would be nothing to do because
you'd be everything at once.
And when you're everything at once,
which is at least in principle,
the position of God.
There's no story,
there's no being,
and there's something about being that
is a story and without limitation
there's no story,
so then the question starts to become
with regards to consideration of human
vulnerability,
is there a way to conduct your life in
such a manner that the intrinsic
vulnerability that characterizes your
life is rendered not only acceptable but
desirable,
and to me that's the central question of
existence and I tell you I get that
wrong.
You're on the wrong track and if you're
on the wrong track,
man,
you are in one terrible place.
I would say with regards to tragedy,
right?
Humans are vulnerable and that's tragic,
but if tragedy is the price that we pay
for existence,
then so be it.
If existence is justifiable and so
tragedy itself,
which is merely a revelation of our
vulnerability,
can't be regarded as evil.
It's just A.
It's a condition of existence and so
it's necessary to distinguish the tragic
conditions of existence from evil before
you can even address the problem.
And I think what that means to some
degree is you should not blame on the
relationship between the finite and the
infinite.
The terrible failings of humanity that
can be laid directly at the feet of
human beings,
so earthquakes aren't evil and cancer
isn't evil and mental illness isn't evil
and predators aren't evil.
They just are part of the way things
are,
but there are certain categories of
human action that are definitely outside
the parameters of mirror tragedy and
those are the things we really have to
get a handle on.
Evil for me is differentiated from
tragedy by its lack of necessity and
it's volunteerism and its attendant.
I think of modern materialistic thought
that there are social or material causes
for actions and it's an extraordinarily
useful theory and I think,
but I think one of the unfortunate
consequences of that is that we've
tended to write off much of human
misbehavior and attributed to say
insufficiencies and material conditions,
which isn't.
It's not an.
It's not an acceptable theory.
There are all sorts of human cultures
that were characterized by virtually
complete absence of material luxury
wellbeing,
whose culture is we're highly functional
and highly moral,
and to describe the propensity towards
misbehavior as a consequence of economic
inequality is entirely beside the point.
As far as I'm concerned,
evil is more pernicious than that which
has generated,
for example,
by social inequality.
I think it's actually,
although this is a terrifying thought,
in some ways it's more appropriate to
consider it a form of a demonically
warped aesthetic,
and I'll give you a couple of examples
of what I mean by that,
for example,
because the exam,
because the manifestation of this warped
athetic aesthetic makes itself apparent
under certain conditions.
So for example,
I think it made itself apparent in the
imagination of the first politician who
coined the acronym a mad or mutually
assured destruction.
That's an aesthetic of evil to to make a
joke of a situation that catastrophic
indicates the kind of malevolence that
lurks behind the fact that such a
condition exists.
The motto on the gates of Auschwitz,
I believe in the Second World War work
will make you free.
That's another manifestation of this
authentic of evil.
It's a terrible,
terrible,
ironic joke and it's instructive to
meditate on what sort of imagination
would have the arrogance to tell such a
terrible joke.
The concentration camps are classic
examples of evil one,
I think by an analyzing at least certain
kinds of events that occurred within
them,
it's easier to get a clear idea of what
evil constitutes in one of the stories.
It's always haunted me,
I guess is,
I believe it's another story derived
from Auschwitz.
The prison guards in Auschwitz would
take the prisoners who were already
stripped of their dignity and to
whatever degree possible their identity
and their culture and their language and
their status of as valuable beings.
And yet that wasn't sufficient.
They needed to be tortured in addition
to that before they were killed.
And the torture often consisted of a
self evidently counterproductive work.
Uh,
uh,
a situation that also frequently
characterized activity in the Soviet
Gulag archipelago where perhaps 60
million people met their death.
A typical Auschwitz example was the
requirement for prisoners to carry 100
pound sacks of wet salt from one side of
the compound and then back again.
Now that's evil as far as I'm concerned
and and you have to think about it from
an aesthetic perspective in a sense
because it's a celebration of horror and
it's a.
it's a conscious attempt to violate the
conditions that make life itself
tolerable and it's aimed at
dehumanization destruction of the ideal
and at an even deeper level revenge
against the conditions of existence
itself.
I've tried to understand it.
Developmental pathway that leads to acts
like that.
My academic research as well as my
clinical experience has revealed to me
that what appears to lie at the bottom
of motivation for the excesses of
behavior that characterize evil are too
tightly,
causally related factors.
One arrogance and other resentment and
both of those are tied up with
vulnerability of human beings
in the face of the infinite,
but
but tied up with something more profound
as well.
The most thorough account of this that
I've managed,
I think,
at least a partially comprehend,
I believe is contained in the first
couple of the stories in the Old
Testament,
in Genesis,
the story of Adam and eve in the fall of
man and the immediately following story
of Cain and Abel.
As far as we can tell,
those are very,
very old stories.
They predate Judaism,
at least in some of their in some of
their structural elements.
It's conceivable that some of the
elements in those stories are as old as
the human capacity to tell stories
itself,
assuming that they were grounded in an
oral tradition that predated the written
tradition and we know that oral
traditions can last at least in some
forms unchanged for periods of up to
25,000
years.
So the anthropological and archeological
evidence is fairly clear on that point.
These are very,
very,
very old stories and people remember
them and created them for reasons we
really don't understand and they're
strange and mysterious and unforgettable
all at the same time.
The story of Adam and Eve as far as I
can tell,
is the story of the coming of
consciousness,
the coming of self consciousness to
mankind,
and I think that the human,
the,
the human human self consciousness is
what separates us from animals.
In Genesis.
There's an insistence that went out to
meet the apple that eve offered to him.
The scales fell from his eyes and the
first thing that he realized was that he
was naked.
And what that seems to me to mean is
that,
I mean,
I think it means first of all,
that women make men self conscious and I
think there's ample reason to presume
that and there's good evolutionary
reasons for suggesting why that might be
the case because sexual selection among
human beings has been a primary force of
evolutionary development.
And sexual selection in human beings is
primarily conducted by women.
So for example,
as Roy has pointed out in his address to
the APA a few years ago,
and I hope I get this right twice as
many of your relatives who were women as
well as men.
And that means that women are more
frequently reproductively successful
than men,
and that they reject most Matt and the
rejection of a man for reproductive
purposes by a woman is the most serious
form of rejection that's possible from
an evolutionary point of view because
the judgment is that what you might be
nice enough to talk to,
whoever you're sure not fit to have your
genes propagate into the next
generation.
So it's no wonder that women can make
self,
make men self conscious.
And I think there's some reason to
presume that it's the sexual selection
forces that women placed upon man that
drove rapid human cortical evolution and
the development of self consciousness.
Now that's a leap and then there's no
way I can justify that the course of
this particular talk.
But I think there is good reason to
presume that it's the case in genesis.
Human beings become self conscious and
the first thing that happens to them is
that they realized they they're naked.
And then the next thing that happens to
them as they develop the moral sense to
tell the difference between good and
evil.
And it's a very strange thing because in
some sense,
before our creature is self conscious,
there is no distinction between good and
evil because as I said before,
a Predator is not evil.
It's just a predator.
The fact of a Predator like a wolf might
be a tragedy for the rabbit,
but you can't be assuming that the wolf
is evil merely because it wants to eat
the rabbit.
But with the dawning of self
consciousness,
there there seems to be the emergence of
a moral sense that's essentially unique
to human beings and that has something
to do with our capacity to reflect upon
the mechanisms of our action.
And then for some reason to be able to
modify those actions and to choose which
ones to implement into the future and
the future.
We don't understand that and you can
even deny if you'd like that the the
phenomena of free choice exists.
But our culture is essentially
predicated on the notion that it does
exist.
And in the absence of evidence that it
doesn't.
I'm going to take the easy way out and
assume that it does.
Otherwise,
things fall apart and they fall apart
badly
when
after Adam and eve become self
conscious,
the first thing they do is closed
themselves and to me,
that's a mythological description of the
emergence of culture as an intercession
between the Ne,
the fundamental vulnerability and
nakedness of the human form and the
depredations of nature.
If you realize that you're vulnerable
and prone to death,
the first thing you're going to do is to
start rearranging the manner in which
you construe yourself so that you can
protect yourself from suction
unfortunate outcome.
So I think partly why God curses Adam
with the necessity of work.
Once he finds out,
once God finds out that people have
become self conscious,
like if you know that what's the winter
is lurking in the future,
for example,
you are going to work and animals don't
work.
They're just motivated to do whatever
they do,
but humans work and that means they
subvert their day to day motivations,
their immediate motivations for the
purposes of future security.
And there's a real cost to that.
Part of the cost is separation from the
pure and unadulterated flow of animal
life.
And I believe that people suffer from
that absence of flow continually and
and,
and the advantage that they gained from
it is that they can plan for the future,
but the disadvantages that they are
calculating and cold and separated from
their own instinctual resources,
eve,
of course,
is cursed by what's going to be terrible
pain in childbirth and that's related to
the development of the immense skull
size that characterizes human infants
and they're incredibly lengthy period of
dependence,
which is also associated with their
immense spring
after Adam and eve become self
conscious.
They hide and this is actually a comical
of genesis.
It's never really read as a comedy,
but it is a comedy.
Even the fall itself as a comedy,
and so they're hiding away behind a Bush
and God comes to walking through the
garden.
And God,
the infinite is accustomed to walking
without him with no interruption of the
flow of information between them.
Madame is narrowed and God says,
you know,
where,
where have you gone?
And Adam says,
well,
I'm hiding.
And God says,
which is kind of stupid really?
And this is why it's a common.
It's like he's hiding behind a bush.
This is God,
and he can see through bushes and like
Adam should know that it doesn't really
matter.
He's hiding out in this Bush anyways.
And uh,
and got so Adam says,
I'm hiding.
And God says,
well,
why are you know,
what,
why are you hiding?
Because Adam's ashamed.
And Adam says,
well,
I'm naked.
And this is an example of the tremendous
compression of human wisdom into a few
lines that characterizes mythologies.
Say,
well,
why would people hide from God once they
realized they're naked?
And I would say,
well,
that's pretty obvious.
Once you know you're vulnerable.
All right.
Do you really have enough courage to
manifest any sort of semblance of a
divine destiny?
Well,
the answer that is pretty much clearly
know,
and it's no bloody wonder.
And so the hiding is people hide when
they're self conscious and vulnerable.
No.
Are they hide from them?
They hide from their deepest destiny and
it's no wonder God says,
okay,
yeah,
well,
you figured that out.
How that happened?
And Adam says,
Mrs.
Carmen was the woman's fault,
which I think is really funny in which
actually may have been the original sin
and not the eating of the apple,
right?
The first time that the man blamed the
woman for his self conscious misery.
I think that's the real fall and knock
the rise of self consciousness itself.
Anyways,
we knew the rest of the story.
God says,
Oh,
well,
the cat's out of the bag.
Now you know,
you know you're vulnerable and from here
on in history starts,
you're out of paradise here,
out of unconscious identification with
the natural world,
you're gonna work.
You're gonna sweat.
Lots of the time it isn't going to work,
and women,
they are going to be beholding to their
husbands,
not because that's divine theater,
but because the developmental,
the developmental dependency of the
human infant is so extreme that women
are cursed to rely on men for protection
when they're at their most vulnerable,
fine.
So that's self consciousness and an
explanation for why people would hide
away from their destiny,
but then the next story that can enable
story really elaborates that out and
describes it.
And so cain and Abel,
of course,
our two sons of Adam and eve,
and they're really the first people
because of course Adam and eve were made
by God,
so they're really not people at all
because people are born and Cain and
Abel are the first two people and they
characterize as far as I can tell,
to canonical patterns of reaction to the
terrible vulnerability that's revealed
as a consequence of the development of
self consciousness.
Cain and Abel make sacrifices to God.
Why?
Human cultures make sacrifices.
That's what they do.
Sacrifice sacrificial rituals.
A human universal blood sacrifices.
A human universal human sacrifice,
at least in some anthropological at was
regarded as a human universal.
Why do people make sacrifices to God?
To please him?
Seems like a mystery to modern people.
I ask my students,
what sacrifices did you make to go to
university?
While they can answer that in two tenths
of a second,
they can't party as much as they might
have.
They.
They can't drink nearly as much beer as
they might've liked to more seriously.
A lot of them work.
A lot of them have put their families in
in,
in serious financial straits to send
them to university.
They've given up all sorts of things in
order to pursue,
pursue a course of action that they
believe will best ensure they're
harmonious relationship with the nature
of reality.
Everyone makes sacrifices.
Okay,
we can say that now because we're a
psychologically sophisticated and
linguistically sophisticated.
We know something about human
psychology,
but thousands and thousands of years ago
before people had this explicit
psychological acumen,
the best they could do is act out and
tell stories about human psychology
because they hadn't developed any
further than that.
And cain and Abel is one of those
stories.
The sacrifices are burnt on an altar.
Why?
Well,
the smoke rises well,
so what?
Well go ends up in the sky and if the
smoke rises up there and he gets a whiff
of it,
he can tell what the quality of the
sacrifice was and you can laugh about
that and you can think of.
You can think about a desk primitive,
but it's not permitted.
It's artistic and it's beautiful and
it's.
And it's accurate.
And here's why,
is because before the invention of the
electrical light and maybe before the
invention of fire,
the closest to human being could ever
give to direct confrontation with the
absolute unknown,
was to look up at the night sky because
the night story,
especially when it sprinkled with stars
confronts you directly with the fact of
the infinite and to make the
presupposition that God resides in the
incident and you're having a direct
experience of the infinite at that
moment is not a primitive notion.
It's a.
it's a very intelligent and creative
hypothesis,
and so the notion that God occupies the
sky,
the days guy being equally as impressive
as the night sky is not a primitive
hypothesis.
It's a reflection of the nature of a
certain kind of human experience.
You burn something and you send the
smoke up.
God gets a crack at determining the
quality of your offering,
the quality of your sacrifice.
Well,
let's get.
Let's be perfectly clear about this.
If your sacrifices aren't first grade,
the nature of your relationship with the
infinite is going to suffer dreadfully.
And that's exactly what the story of
Cain and Abel reveals now able.
He's interesting character.
He believes in the nature of experience
and the nature of existence when he's
called on to make a sacrifice,
he sacrifices the best that he has to
offer and that makes God happy.
And as a consequence,
everything that Abel touches turns to
gold.
Everyone likes him,
they respect him,
his crops multiply.
He's successful women.
Plus he's a wonderful guy,
so you could hardly imagine a more
annoying creature if you possibly
attempted to do it.
Whereas cain see cain has reacted to his
self consciousness by withdrawing from
the infinite.
And there's a tremendous danger in that
because it starts to mean that he
realized purely on his own devious
devices to sale is shipped through the
shoulders of life.
He believes as his arrogance developed
as a consequence of his withdrawal from
the infinite,
the contact that he can't tolerate
because he can't tolerate his own
vulnerability.
That he's able to deceive the structure
of reality itself,
to offer second rate sacrifices to God
himself who can see absolutely
everything because the infinite is
absolutely everything and to prevail.
Nonetheless,
well,
needless to say,
this does not work and it doesn't work
in an obvious way.
If you talk to people and they reveal to
you they're unnecessary suffering,
it's very straightforward to look behind
what it is that they have to say.
They'll tell you the poor decisions they
made in their lives and the
opportunities that they didn't take and
the chances that they didn't.
They didn't have enough courage to grasp
and the sacrifices they failed to make.
There's nothing mysterious about it and
their own experiences teach them full
well that they pathologize the
relationship they have with the nature
of reality.
Well,
that's a terrible thing.
Well in Kane is dreadfully unhappy.
He's unhappy because nothing he ever
wants happens and that's partly because
he doesn't really want it because if he
really wanted it,
he'd make the right sacrifices to salt
is rubbed into his wounds by the
existence of his brother for whom
everything seemed simple,
but of course really isn't.
Cane goes to complain to God and I had
to read three or four different
translations of these particular verses
to figure out what this meant.
Penny says,
what in the world is going on here?
I'm marketing myself to the bone.
I'm sacrificing things left,
right and center.
Everything I touch turns to dirt.
Everything turns against me like what's
up with the nature of reality canes?
Essential vulnerability is revealed and
exacerbated by his pathological attitude
towards his own actions.
God says to him,
essentially sin is a predatory cat that
crouches at your doorway and leaps on us
will it,
but if you only wanted to,
you could master it,
and that is absolutely the last thing
that Kayden wants to hear because if
things are going from bad to worse for
you and you're playing a causal role in
it,
there is nothing more horrible than some
that someone can do to you,
but reveal to you in a way that you can
deny that you're entirely complicit in
your own demise and that's exactly what
God does to cane,
and so what is can do?
Well,
the logical thing would be listened
because if the structure of reality
itself tells you something,
it's best to listen since there is no
way out of it,
but that's not what kin does.
He's so incensed by his essential
vulnerability,
compromised and exacerbated by his
failure to make the appropriate
sacrifices in,
to conduct himself appropriately,
that he decides that in there,
number one,
to destroy his ideal,
to reduce the tension that he feels when
that ideal exists as a contrast point
and number two,
to destroy the favorite son of God,
and so he goes out into the field and
kills Abel and God comes along and says,
where's my favorite Sonnen?
Cain says,
I killed him and it's so interesting to
me that that story is placed.
Really it's the third story in the Old
Testament.
It's,
it's with the archaic stories and it's a
story that reveals as far as I can tell,
that there are two essential patterns of
reaction to the self conscious,
vulnerable conditions of existence,
and one is humble approach to an
infinity with determined attempt to make
the appropriate sacrifices.
The other is arrogance,
resentment,
the keeping of everything good for
oneself and the degeneration of the soul
into something that's homicidally
murderous.
Well,
the story doesn't stop there and it gets
really compressed in this part and
that's perhaps because some of it's been
lost with the passages of time,
but the next thing that happens is that,
well,
God doesn't punish cane anything.
That's Kinda strange.
I mean the Old Testament God,
he's punishing people left,
right,
and center.
It's right.
Why not cane and you think,
well,
he marks cane and he says to the people
who are around that they should leave
him alone because he's been marked by
God as to be left alone.
And the reason for that I think,
and this is something that's reflected
on our legal system,
is that murder promotes revenge and
revenge,
destroy societies,
and so God puts an end to the situation
right there and then by telling people
that despite the fact that cane has,
has committed a terrible crime,
that there will be no retribution.
Cannon goes off and gets married and he
has a number of generations of
offspring.
If you insult a member of the first
generation of keynes offspring,
he doesn't kill you.
It killed seven of you.
And if you insult a member of the second
generation of Keynes offspring,
he doesn't kill seven of you,
he killed seven times,
seven of you,
and then on down the rate down the road
of the offspring of Cain is tubilcain.
Tubilcain is the artificer of weapons of
war.
And this stunningly brilliant story says
in it's incredibly compressed fashion,
that the motivation that drives the
commission of the worst human atrocities
isn't inevitable.
Social consequence of the refusal of the
self conscious individual to make the
sacrifices appropriate to establishing a
harmonious life and there consequent
degeneration into a kind of murderous
and resentment filled raged rage
propagating endlessly through its
variations in society until everything
comes to an end.
And the next story is the flood.
And it's not surprising because if
things go from bad to worse,
long enough,
everything falls.
And it's a terrifying story.
And I didn't understand that story.
I didn't understand that story for
years.
It wasn't really until I read Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn that,
that,
that I develop,
I think the cognitive capacity to even
understand what the story meant.
Because Solzhenitsyn said in his Nobel
Prize accepting speech,
a single person who stopped lying can
bring down a tyranny,
which is a stunning thing to say,
but I would also say something that's
been amply demonstrated in the 20th
century because we have the.
We have historical examples of people
who did precisely that.
Got Them.
He did it in fact,
well,
how well did it Nelson Mandela did it,
Solzhenitsyn's gulag.
Archipelago was definitely one of the
acs blows that brought down the Soviet
Union a stunning achievement for a
person who started writing that book by
memorizing it when he was a
concentration camp victim this far away
from starvation.
It shows you as clearly as anything
possibly can,
how powerful the human spirit can be if
it's willing to take on the obligation
of its relationship with the divine and
also how terrible things can become.
If the responsibility of that burden is
not children.
Now it's no wonder as far as I can tell
that people don't think this way because
thinking this way is,
it's catastrophic in a way because the
burden it places on the individual is so
extreme that it's almost unbearable
while in,
uh,
but,
but that's exactly why it is in genesis
to begin with it.
Adam hides.
He becomes conscious of his own
vulnerability.
It's like he thinks,
well,
a creature such as I could never bear
such a burden.
Well,
there's a lot more to people than meets
the eye.
And the only way I learned that was by
looking at people's and my own peoples
in my own capacity for evil because I
started to realize that we regard
ourselves as narrow little beings in a
particular kind of box.
And there's real comfort in that older.
There's tremendous limitation.
You cannot see your way out of that box
until,
you know what I teach my students.
I teach them about Nazi Germany and I
try to make them understand that there's
an overwhelming probability if they were
in Nazi Germany in the 19 thirties,
that they would've been perpetrators and
Nazis and overwhelming probability.
And if they can't accept that because
it's a historical fact,
they have absolutely no idea who they
are now,
imagining yourself as a Nazi
perpetrators an unbearably terrifying
thing to do,
but I don't believe that you can do it.
I don't think that you have any insight
whatsoever into your capacity for good
until you have some well-developed
insight into your capacity for evil
because people can tell you until
they're blue in the face about your
capacity for good.
It just sounds like a.
It sounds like wishful thinking.
It sounds like this sort of thing that
an advertiser might tell you on TV.
It's just too good to be true and I
don't think believe it,
but I think that if you tell people that
you know in a cold,
dark corners of their mind,
there are motivations that are so
terrible that they would.
They would traumatize themselves if they
were ever revealed that everyone knows
at some level of analysis that that's
absolutely true.
You think there's evidence throughout
history that it's possible for people to
be enlightened and you would think since
enlightenment is viewed as the
medication for vulnerability in death,
that everybody would be struggling as
hard as they possibly could to be
enlightened if such a state exactly and
precisely exists,
but if the barrier to enlightenment is
the development of self consciousness,
of the individual humans,
infinite capacity for evil,
then you can be immediately convinced
about why enlightenment is in such short
supply.
When I
finished my first provisional
examination of the sorts of motivations
that drove people to set up
concentration camps and to torture
people terribly and those camps,
I came to a terrible conclusion,
a conclusion that I think in some ways
was the worst thing that had ever
happened to me,
maybe intellectually and morally.
I thought I came to understand why it is
that people depended on their group
identity and their cultural
identification because that helped
protect themselves from their own
vulnerability.
You have to believe things because you
just don't know everything,
so you have to believe things.
They fill in the gaps to bleach,
fill in the gaps.
If the beliefs are stripped from you,
then your defenses against the infinite
are stripped and it's no wonder that
people will defend their beliefs.
I thought,
well you do.
If you're too involved in defending your
beliefs,
you're going to be willing to kill other
people in their defense and we're so
technologically powerful now that we can
no longer be willing to kill other
people in the defense of our own beliefs
because the time for that is passed and
I realized,
well,
if you don't stand up for your beliefs,
you leave yourself open to the
depredations of the infinite.
That's equally intolerable.
It seems to leave no way out.
There is a way out.
You know,
and I think it's the way out that
genuinely religious people have tried to
offer humanity for thousands and
thousands of years and the way out of
the conundrum posed to you by your
reliance on ideological beliefs and your
vulnerability in the face of the unknown
is the development of a truly integrated
and powerful character.
And that's a individual development.
And it means constant confrontation with
things you don't understand and constant
attempts to ensure that your character
is composed of truth and solidity rather
than deceit and to make of yourself
something that's built on a rock and not
predicated on sand.
And the thing is,
it's one thing to tell people that
because maybe they should take care of
themselves,
but I don't know if that's enough to
tell people because they don't take care
of themselves that well.
But it's a completely other thing to
say,
look,
you know,
every time you make a pathological moral
decision,
you move the one world one step closer
to complete annihilation.
And I absolutely believe that.
I think the historical evidence is
crystal clear.
And I also think that every time you
make an appropriate moral decision and
you manifest moral courage in the face
of your own vulnerability,
then you move the world one step farther
from the break.
And every that's the case for every
single person.
You know,
Solzhenitsyn said,
drawing on his eastern Orthodox
Christian background.
Every single person is the center of the
world as center of the world,
not the center of the world.
The world's a complicated place.
It can have all sorts of centers.
It's hard to believe that you might be
one of them,
but everything about human existence is
hard to believe.
The fact that it's here at all,
it's hard to believe the nature of.
It's hard to believe everything that
human beings does.
It's so ridiculous and remarkable that
it's like it's a consistently and
constantly unfolding miracle.
The idea that each of you might be a
center of the cosmos in that infinite
admixture of ridiculousness and now
absurdities is hardly more than one more
ridiculous thing to swallow.
Well,
I'll summarize,
I guess said that tragedy is a
precondition for being.
Being is the interplay between the
finite and the infinite,
and in that interplay,
there's tragedy.
There's no way out of that evil
something different evils.
The conscious attempt to make the
conditions of existence more
pathological than they have to be and
it's motivated by conscious intent.
The motivations arise because people pay
a terrible price for their self
conscious awareness and that awareness
is there awareness of their
vulnerability and that is a terrible
thing to be aware of.
That vulnerability can be confronted,
forthrightly accepted,
and the appropriate decisions made.
Alternatively,
people can retreat into their own
rationalistic arrogance and attempt to
deceive themselves and everyone else
about the nature of their own existence
and about the nature of reality.
That pathway leads to nothing but
destruction.
I think that there's good reason to
assume that it's too late in the day in
our developmental course as a species
for that path to be acceptable anymore
because we're too powerful and if too
many people stay on that path,
we're going to do ourselves in.
And so I would say as we've become more
technologically powerful and increasing
moral burden is being placed on each of
us.
It matters to the,
to the,
to the destiny of the cosmos.
Whether or not you get your moral act
straight,
and I don't mean that in a trivial way.
I believe that that's as close to an
empirical fact is anything that can be
demonstrated,
and I also believe that's as terrifying
a thing to consider as anything you
could possibly imagine and maybe it's
too much to ask of people,
but you know,
our great religious traditions do
continually remind us that insight,
every human being,
there's a spark of divinity and that
idea is a precondition for our entire
system of law.
There's always the possibility that it's
true and if it's true,
it means that there is a.
there's a,
there's an infant and avenue of
potential that lays open to every single
person and that the ability to transform
the terrible conditions of reality into
something not only acceptable but worthy
of celebration actually lies within our
grasp and the alternative that the
alternative to that is the continual
generation of a kind of held that so
incomprehensibly awful that by any
reasonable person's standards,
it has to be regarded as something to
avoid.
That's all I have to say about that.
Thank you.